we need to think very carefully about
what we mean when we use the term
American Dream and this is been the
subject of several recent books that
have come out including some easy
coats's between the world and Maine in
which coats really pushes back against
the dream as a concept I'm interested in
in work that asks us to consider what is
at stake when we imagine someone who has
met or checked off the boxes that we
associate with the American dream so on
the one hand I went to all of these
institutions that are viewed as markers
of a certain kind of success at the same
time though it's imperative that we
think about ways of succeeding in
American society that go beyond some of
the traditional attributes of the
American Dream and this now brings me
back to undocumented migrant so on the
one hand many undocumented migrants are
not in my position they for many reasons
our hindered or have been hindered in
attaining their dreams but one of the
reasons that we think of dreamers and
one of the reasons why the undocumented
youth movement has taken up that label
enthusiastically is because we believe
that it is even at these margins of
American society these margins that are
created by u.s. immigration policy that
so much amazing work is being done by
families by communities to commit
wholeheartedly to the pursuit of this
thing we call the American dream these
are migrants who have contributed to
their communities who have worked hard
and with persistence to ensure the very
best for their children in a word they
exemplify everything that we
conventionally associate with the
American dream and for those migrants to
be labeled as an American almost beggars
the mind
it calls into question why in fact we
have this designation the American dream
in the first place if we're not willing
to extend it to anyone and everyone who
works hard to make this country a better
place
you